everybody this
is congratulations
[Music]
yes we did it yes we did it yes we did
it it's 200 and something episode i
never know because sometimes i just do
episodes and then we just find out what
episode they're gonna be later and
that's what this is
that's what this is um
strong guys i took a break haven't
worked out in the past few days because
my um
my hip hurt a little bit
and i'm an alarmist so i was walking
around the house saying i fractured my
hip and then uh kristen was like you
didn't fracture your hip and i was like
how do you know oh you're a doctor
she was like no but you didn't fracture
your hip because you wouldn't be able to
walk
so i googled it and she's right it's
very very very unlikely you could walk
if you fractured a hip uh but turns out
that if you're over the age of 50 and
you fracture your hip
you have a
chance
of dying yay didn't know that didn't
mean to start out the podcast on such a
sad note but it's true dude why because
of things like sepsis and sepsis and i
pretty much know so much stuff now i'll
forget that in a week i don't really
retain
info at all like i was just reading
about robotics
and
uh sorry watching a video about robotics
and forgot about it immediately i saw it
about 10 minutes ago and i literally was
watching a video thinking whoa i should
remember that and i already forgot it so
there's no hope and it's all good i
can't retain [ __ ] all right dude i got
friends who can retain [ __ ] all the time
gotta be got a bad memory can't retain
ship and my hip is fractured so it's all
good uh but yeah dude you get older and
you get older and as you're getting
older your [ __ ] starts hurting and it
hurts everywhere i got my hip my back my
jaw um
and a little [ __ ] gas bubble in my
tummy that won't really go away and i
can't remember anything so and i'm only
41 dude um
so my buddy and i used to do a joke
about we used to stop we did we just
stopped to each other
so far and we used to stop we used to be
talking in a conversation and then i
would be like hey man i've been lying to
you the whole time i'm actually 48
and he would be like what dude oh my god
why would you lie and i said i know i
wanted you to like me i don't know
i just i'm 48 years old and i thought it
was cool if i was 30.
and we would laugh so hard stupid jokes
with your friends or this [ __ ] if you
don't have stupid jokes with your
friends that friendship ain't [ __ ] if
you don't have if you don't secretly
hate your friends too friendship ain't
[ __ ] um
so yeah
it's all good dude um
and don't forget dude to uh want to dine
that like button if you're a fan of this
video really helps if you subscribe but
don't just subscribe take the
subscription button out on a date you
know what i mean and uh offered to take
it on a day date be nice be a gentleman
about it go to a matinee with that bell
notification button i feel like when i
do these when i talk about these they
kind of get lost and people go hahaha
and don't click the shits but click the
shits click the shit's my babies
um
but yeah we're rolling we're rolling on
you know and i'm rolling on my dolo dude
a lot of people claim to be [ __ ]
you know
the best podcasts or the while and out
most wild and out podcasts and this is
the best most while in
so um
you know congratulations dude it's
congratulations that's what it is
um
you know we twitch on stream on mondays
flex avenue go out and get your merch
you can go get that go medium or
sometimes stay out i was uh i was
chilling and somebody uh drove by me the
other day and he said hey man don't
forget to go medium and i go all right
that's the end of that story it was bad
but it was short it's okay to tell a bad
story as long as it's short okay uh was
out to eat at a restaurant last night uh
with a bunch of friends um and uh there
were like nine or ten of us
and it was at this place called aroma
aroma on sunset and it is unbelievably
first of all it's a place where you can
get food food isn't bad
always drove by this place brighter than
[ __ ]
brighter than [ __ ]
okay restaurants that are brighter than
[ __ ]
you know lower the level a little bit
right you don't need restaurants to be
brighter than [ __ ] make it a little bit
nice make it have some ambiance unless
it's a diner if it's a diner brighter
than [ __ ] kind of the charm okay but a
restaurant better than [ __ ]
no also they had the heat lamps on also
it's august in l.a also was sweating
took off my sweatshirt
okay ate a santa fe spicy chicken wrap
first bite
squirted out onto my t-shirt sew back
goes on the sweatshirt
sweatshirt was back on stain was
underneath hotter than [ __ ] but still
looking nice
fashion is pain
um
so i was there with a bunch of friends
and dude this guy first of all it's the
loudest [ __ ] place dude everybody
there has this face on
it's super la and everyone there has
that face on and uh nobody's having fun
everybody has work done there uh they
all got faces that look like aliens
and it's the only place open in l.a now
for some reason la closes it shuts down
i guess it's because the pandemic or
whatever the [ __ ] people are hurting
financially i don't know what it is they
don't have the servers that are [ __ ]
doing this [ __ ] late at night i don't
know what it is but this place aroma
was the only place that was open so we
went
and they played the music too
loud they play the music too loud they
play the music's loud and it's too
bright yeah and they keep the heat
lengths on in august yay dude and it's a
restaurant and they also
have a guy dude they have a hookah they
have hookahs dude yeah it's the most
annoying place on the planet yay
it's too hot too loud too bright and
smelly yay
dude you can get a santa fe
wrap
eat it
you can get a santa fe wrap eat it
and then you can say hey why are those
guys smoking hookahs
and then you go and the guy says would
you like to smoke a hookah and you don't
say yes but the people you're with say
yes because they want to smoke a hookah
and so they say let me get the hookah
guy they have their own hookah guy at
the restaurant yay
yay did they have their own hookah guy
at the restaurant do hookah places or
hookah places restaurants should be
restaurants don't fuse the hookah place
with the restaurant
and uh i'll tell you why i'll tell you
why because when i eat a spicy santa fe
chicken wrap
i don't want vape smoke in my face all
right ruins the whole vibe ruins the
whole vibe dude ruins the whole vibe
it's also one of those places where they
ask you what you want to eat and then
you tell them what you want to eat and
they say are you going to want dessert
and you say in your head well how the
[ __ ] do i know if i want dessert or not
because i didn't even eat my centipede
chicken spicy wrap yet
and then they say well we need to know
ahead of time because the dessert takes
25 minutes to make don't
pull that [ __ ] on me man make a bunch
dude make a bunch
make a bunch and i'll order them later
okay
when somebody says
that's a cuda that's the cuda [ __ ] dude
when you fall for that well it takes us
25 minutes to make it you go oh
yes i'll try the [ __ ] chocolate lava
it's always a chocolate lava thing
it's never anything but a chocolate lava
i don't know what it is they have to
like make it and put the lava in it
and they go yeah one and and two of two
of my homies there were like yeah we'll
get it so two of them got it and it came
and i didn't i said no i don't wanna i
don't wanna how am i gonna know i gotta
want it it's gonna take 25 minutes if i
want it then i just won't get it then
dude if you want me to play the game
dude i'm out how about that okay
i'm out i'll be an audience member in
this game and i'm fine with that i'm the
guy screaming no emmys know where's the
whammies i'm not the guy doing it
and i'm fine with that
when that cake came my buddy came
my buddy had it and i i i asked to try
it and i tried it once and i ate it and
i only did one bite with the scoop with
the ice cream in it and it was so
[ __ ] good wish i got it
so you live and you learn dude you live
and you learn but it was too loud and it
was [ __ ] bright as [ __ ] and smelly
dude the hookah [ __ ] has just gotta go
what is it what is it dude my buddy was
doing it like this
look i was like dude you look like
you're sucking a dick and then he was
going like this
while he was smoking on it dude and we
were laughing so [ __ ] hard he was
just like
you know what i mean so immature um he's
37. so um
yeah man but it was hot as [ __ ] dude but
sometimes you just [ __ ] go out and
you have fun with the fellas man it was
like old times it was like no covid
pre-fucking pre-covered pre-everything
man and it was fun man
and that's all i have to say about that
and that was a long story there was a
bad short one and then a long one that
was fine
um
[Music]
so yeah i i don't know dude i like uh i
like i like those hangs man i love
[ __ ] hanging you ever talk about you
ever think about
like
you know some guys like to stay home and
i like to stay home sometimes but
i haven't hung out in the past like year
and a half because of the pandemic and
everything and like you know [ __ ] has
gone
just
shh everything's shut down
that things are kind of back but not
totally and i went to hang out i guess
last night really if i'm being
honest was my first real hardcore hang
dude and by that i mean i went to two
places you know what i mean i wound up
at the diner or the whatever the [ __ ]
the restaurant is
you know it wasn't just we went to the
restaurant you know sometimes we go to a
restaurant and christian's like let's go
out to another place and i'm just like
oh i'm tired but i forced myself and i
did it and it was fun dude i suggest it
man
i walked into the place
um and when i walked into the place
there was like one of the first of all
there's a rope thing like a rope to like
you can't get in like so i'm like okay
uh that's how i walk around the rope and
i walk up to the stair i walk up the
stairs i got my mask on and the guy's
like and i go to and i wave to the
security guy i guess and i go to
because my buddy's already there sitting
down and he goes like this yo yo where
you going where you going and i'm like
oh dude i'm i'm going to grab the table
that my buddy's at and he's like no no
that ain't how it works man and i'm like
what
and he was like hold up hold up and i'm
like okay my buddy's over there and he's
like
where what's going on and i'm like
dude i don't understand what's going on
what the issue is but uh my buddy has
this has seats for us at the table over
there and the guy goes like this the guy
goes like this
all right man
shorten it up
who's this what's this guy doing i don't
i [ __ ] can't stand jobs that aren't
jobs
that just took longer there's just a guy
now in my way
his job is just
guy in the way
dude how are you just that's your job
hey you hey what are you oh i'm a
[ __ ] i make i make [ __ ] choo choo
trains oh what do you do i'm a banker
what do you do oh i'm guy i'm standing
around the guy i'm also known as guy in
the way
these [ __ ] jobs dude it's like
hollywood when they make those movies
about [ __ ] uh
uh about a guy like
who doesn't it's like a job that doesn't
exist like that movie hitch
it's like what is this guy oh this guy
is gonna help you find b he's gonna i'm
will smith and i'll make you fall in
love i'll make you find your soul mate
oh that's not a job dude it's certainly
not a job by a handsome black man that's
a [ __ ] old
72 year old woman that like has way too
many too much jewelry on and like those
funky annie potts and ghostbusters glass
[ __ ] glasses and she's just like i
see don't worry i i got you sweetheart i
got you you got [ __ ] will smith
handsomely [ __ ] 40 years old in a movie
called hitch
about trying to find a soul mate
dude what the [ __ ] it's not a job hey
hollywood don't make a movie about a
[ __ ] guy
who has a job that's not a job
it'll be some movie called like the
[ __ ]
the wedding trucker or some [ __ ] and
it's just like yeah i bring trucks to a
wedding it's like one guy he brings
trucks to a wedding [ __ ] that guy
from king of queens is just like anybody
order a truck falling in love what do
you
want this summer fall in love all over
again
wedding trucker
and [ __ ] what's his names in it that
guy who's in that uh
the the [ __ ] dude who is in the
cinderella movie dancing all around
playing the [ __ ]
ah [ __ ] who cares dude
billy morton maybe his name is i don't
[ __ ] know dude
it doesn't matter dude it doesn't you
know it doesn't matter but what was i
talking about
the jobs that are on jobs so dude it's
like what is this [ __ ] like dude another
one of those jobs is like segment
producer dude
when you do a [ __ ] i've talked about
this on the podcast but when you do
stand up
for a like a show like a late show or a
tonight show there's a guy that comes
out and like is like well let's see what
bits you're going to be doing for the
tonight show and you're just like huh
i'm the comedian yeah but i want to see
what'll work with the show dude
no
no you know
i got it i do this your guy in the way
your guy's standing around saying whoa
whoa whoa when you don't need to dude
move move let me sit hey what are you
the [ __ ] sit down police
whoa what's going on here i'm sitting my
[ __ ] ass down why because i want to
give this establishment money
and they pay you
yeah likely story what do you think what
do you think i'm a [ __ ] cia agent
trying to like do like conduct some sort
of sting over here on this [ __ ] cafe
on sunset boulevard
we were there and
and uh
all of a sudden like the music was so
loud
the pinnacle of the night was the music
was so loud the [ __ ] squirted on my
sweater it was 95 degrees the heat was
on in the summer
in august in la and uh
all of a sudden in the parking lot first
of all i pull up to the valet dude i'm
like hey can i park it myself
and he was like nah
and i was like yeah no and he was like
nah it's only valet and i'm like can can
i just can i leave it here and he was
like yeah yeah sure go ahead get out
here give me the key and i'm like now
you don't get it man
can i park the [ __ ] car you know i
didn't say that but that's how i thought
and i was nice right because i had a
mask on so he couldn't see [ __ ]
and he was like uh
nah you can't and i'm just like
guy in the way dude
two guys in the way
i got to give my car over to some guy
and then i got a [ __ ]
guy in the stairs
hey everybody move right
okay
so i get there and he wouldn't let me
park my own car so i parked on the
[ __ ] street
and then uh and then we're there and i
squirted the [ __ ] on my the santa fe
trick trick santa fe chicken wrap
squirted like it busted a nut right on
my [ __ ] came out like tabasco sauce
right on my [ __ ] put the sweater on now
it's 96 [ __ ] degrees i got a sweater
on
the music is once in so loud and the
[ __ ] hook is blowing doing it like
the [ __ ] the old daffy duck cartoons
where it's under my under my
return the smoke turns into a hand and
says come here but i'm instead of
[ __ ] going with it i'm like ew bro
i'm not [ __ ] doing the hookah what am
i [ __ ] i'm not persian i'm a white
guy
right
or a chilled out black guy that sits
like this
those dudes love hookahs right with a
pack with a pack on over the side that
like with a purse on over his chest
um
and so uh
so i'm sitting there and all the shit's
going on and and then i hear the loudest
[ __ ] rev engine i've ever heard in my
life
right next to me in the valet parking
lot
and it's just
and not just that just again
[Music]
and it's a [ __ ] i look over my
shoulders it's a dodge intrepid of
course dude let me look it up and make
sure it was a dodge intrepid it was a
dodge dude i'll tell you that much dude
don't
how about this don't
rev
any dodge
look at the way i spelled it like a
[ __ ] idiot it wasn't an intrepid of
course dodge charger charger
i just like the [ __ ] intrepid
intrepid dude the dodge charger is it
was what it was and it goes
and he pulls out of the valet dude and
they pull out of the street onto the
street onto sunset boulevard and he goes
to take a left but then he goes
and he goes
and it spins around like vin diesel and
[ __ ] and then he go he ends up
all the way to his face the other way
and then it goes
and then drives it like he took a left
to take a right like a piece of [ __ ]
dude i was so loud and it was so funny
because somebody said oh what if he
didn't do that on purpose one of the
guys at the daily was like what if he
just [ __ ] meant to take a left and
just spun out i mean and i was like yeah
dude he [ __ ] had to keep going to
save face and his girl was in the car
and his girl was like no honey what the
[ __ ] we live over the other way dude and
we were laughing dude we had a good time
man and then everybody said oh this
place sucks and we started laughing so
[ __ ] hard dude comedy and [ __ ]
pain
i um anyway that's my night dude at that
[ __ ] place who cares man who cares i
love you dude i love you guys i love
when you listen
and i love when you chill dude and i
love that you're with me dude on this
podcast and this is a cult dude this is
not a podcast this is a cult you were a
cult member
you know
and i'm a member too dude but i'm the
guy who you know is like let's go and
you guys are like okay you know and we
all wear the same [ __ ] dude i'm just
cannot wait till we get to that [ __ ]
high grass dude i cannot wait till we
get to the high grass and do hymns and
[ __ ] that i sing along you know that i
kind of make up but like i make up as i
go i don't do the [ __ ] like there's no
books we got to read that's for sure
like i'll do that and you'll just try to
do it too
[Laughter]
baby and you know and it's just it's a
good time dude and we're just in high
grass that they should cut it's itching
the [ __ ] out of our abdomens
yeah dude
you know flowy dressings
having a good time man
yeah
gotta get that log cabin with air with
air conditioning
no music no music i saw this thing on
instagram today it was like yo what's it
gonna be
you gotta play michael jordan one on one
and and you gotta score one one point
and you'll get five million dollars or
you'll never listen to music again would
you take it
and i'm like [ __ ] yeah dude i'm trying
to [ __ ] eek music out of my life
i swear to god dude i was watching a
wedding video today tears cascading
tears
cascading dude kristen was like watch
this
tears
cascading all right
it was like [ __ ] some viral wedding
video that was like really good or
something and the guy was just like
my grandma died and she wanted me to
marry this girl and she was like what
are you doing [ __ ] or get off the pot
and so we put a chair out for the for my
grandma even though she's not alive she
has a chair for the wedding
and then he was like crying looking in
his fiance's eyes or his wife's eyes and
i just [ __ ] tears welled the [ __ ] up
dude
um
so yeah
and i [ __ ] cried so i cry all the
time
a lot of these doors is open have opened
up you know do a lot of therapy and all
this [ __ ] i try to listen to more music
now kristen is like you should listen to
more music and i'm just like dude
i'd rather just listen to [ __ ] some
[ __ ] like
you know that rocks
some [ __ ] by like you know gnaws or
or or [ __ ] cool mo d or like david
banner rather than
some [ __ ] that's just going to make me
even 80s nostalgic [ __ ] is like now
crushing me dude like all the walls are
down dude i'm in therapy talking about
all of my feelings and i wasn't before
all this and now i'm talking about all
my feelings and
some [ __ ] [ __ ] song will come on
and it'll just remind me of being a kid
and like i'll be like [ __ ] man my dad's
got limited time left and so does my mom
just
cause [ __ ] we built this city came on
on the radio and i'm just like i can't
get away from these emotions dude
we built this city on rock and roll
that's me not even [ __ ] warmed up
imagine when i did some
you know what i mean
imagine i know i did this a few podcasts
ago but imagine
you know
oh
and then we built this city
that's [ __ ] with two warmings up
we built a city
you go down sometimes right because
people want to always do the regular
notes people always want to sing along
and be like we built
we built this city on rock and roll i'm
not that guy dude rock and roll i'm
[ __ ] rock and roll
i'm that guy dude
i go all sorts of [ __ ] i do runs
anyway it's not important you know my
point is [ __ ] npr sucks
air conditioner was built and anything
and the reason why is because movie
theaters there was a boom shut up dude
shut up people wanted to go to the movie
theaters because there was a crisis and
a heat wave and the air conditioner was
built in the dude shut the [ __ ] up
let's have a silly goose time dude let's
not stop stop learning about dude when
people are like well you
you don't learn about history you're
doomed to repeat it uh you know dude all
right well we're doomed to repeat it
anyway man the [ __ ] keeps happening
like [ __ ] was better in the 60s it was
the same
everyone was fighting each other
there was like
five years where everyone was just
[ __ ] in the 70s and besides that
everything's pretty much been the same
everyone was just naked just [ __ ] in
the 70s it was like four or five years
besides that everyone's kind of been
dying
um
so
yeah
there's this guy dude i saw this clip on
tick tock
i'm on tick tock because i you know what
i mean because your boy
you know why
you know why my viral [ __ ] game just
goes
dummy hard
my viral game goes [ __ ] jesus christ
dude my viral game is so crazy mattel
approached me they go can we i say stop
right there not interested
so i'm watching this [ __ ] thing it's
called first of all he's called the the
the brain doctor or something
first of all don't be a doctor on
tick-tock okay
don't be a doctor on tick-tock dude
you know
like i have a general physician i go to
i'm like man i gotta [ __ ] you know
i think i gotta whenever i got a fissure
in my butt or something man and he's
just like let me give you some pills if
that guy was on tick tock i'd keep the
fissure and never go see him
i'll just bleed when i go
fissures are you know with that stupid
[ __ ] tick tock music behind it
so take to here you know
air conditioners were built because of a
heat wave and
this guy
talking about so he's a brain doctor
and his [ __ ] is
daca man
daniel g
amen
md and this is what he said
one who wants to date his kids they have
to get their brains scanned youngest is
16. okay and
she starts dating michael and
i love michael michael's a good boy
but in my mind they're really not dating
until i see his brain
[Music]
a sentence
but in my mind they're not dating until
i see his brain
it's a cavalier
first of all
what
second of all
huh
hey me man you opening up his head
yex rain is cranium
what you talking about doc
let's see
i mean so cavalier in my mind they're
not dating until i can see his brain
and when michael was 12 his mother
killed herself
okay well all right
so
his daughter's dating this
guy who
he wants to scan his brain and also the
kid's mom killed himself when he was 12.
it's invasive but
would be invasive even if his mom didn't
kill him but whatever let's keep going
and he found her
and i'm like no i need to know
and he's such a good kid scanned his
brain it was busy and he had struggled
with anxiety and on the things that i
recommended for him he's just done so
much better and that
that's an ad grenade
hey dude
don't scan anyone's brain at home
leave it to your [ __ ]
what do you call them
patience
oh so you want to date my daughter huh
sit in this chair dude
i imagine like the clockwork orange
thing where the guys [ __ ] had the two
sugar cubes [ __ ]
and in between the toothpick holding his
eyes open just like
just
showing him atomic bombs and lizards
just really quickly just other eyes and
atomic bombs and lizards and a [ __ ]
building imploding
and then it ends and he's just like okay
have fun at the cinema
be home by 9 30.
he like refers people to us
and yeah you brainwashed them dude you
scanned his brain
my kids i scan the brain of his partner
and i'm like please don't marry her
because it was not good it was not
healthy and
it turned out she had
an addiction issue
that he didn't know about but he didn't
listen to me and that was trouble
um
[Music]
you know
this doctor is dealing with the things
that aren't even the problem
the problem is addiction
work on that
you can't control your dude i'm dr phil
man am i doctor hey hold on a second
dude let me check oh i'm still crystalia
but i'm dr phil to this dude if i'm dr
phil to you and you're a doctor then
dude guess what you're doing it wrong
i flipped into dr phil mode because you
[ __ ] up so much doc you could scan a
br dude
how about dealing with the addiction
dude
hey don't don't
what about letting your kids [ __ ]
make the
find out yourself
you know
your heart gets broken you grow up
yeah remember the [ __ ] yeah i dated
this one person yeah it was tough man
but you know what now i know a little
better
isn't that
whoops
isn't that [ __ ] dude
how weird
imagine calvin coming home hey i like
this chick let me scan her brain cal
aren't you a comedian
it's so weird dude people are so weird
and people with [ __ ] uh like
when a doctor is you know it's like oh
god
doctors do so many drugs you know that
right because they have to do it they're
so mad they're so on like pills
gotta stay up late and they gotta see
[ __ ] babies dying and [ __ ] dude it's
horrible to be a doctor i mean it's
great what you're doing but the [ __ ] you
see
bro i'd be popping so much [ __ ]
just cra i'd be snorting pepto-bismol
no tummy eggs if i'm a doctor
how about when the [ __ ] did you see
the thing about
i just love this
uh
headline james corden dresses as a mouse
and thrusts at drivers to promote new
special the only thing
i mean dude this is on the independent
first of all the movie's cinderella
and uh james corden
is dressed like a [ __ ] mouse
dancing
in
the middle of the street uh
james corden has been spotted dressed as
a mouse and thrusting at drivers in los
angeles to promote his new special why
first of all why is this okay you're
stopping traffic and you're thrust in
your [ __ ]
and you're dressed like a big mouse um
camera footage recorded by a twitter
twitter user blah blah blah uh oh billy
porter i was right that's the guy's name
idina menzel otherwise known as
adel dazeem the wickedly talented adel
dadeem
singing jennifer lopez's let's get loud
in the middle of la traffic who wants to
be in these [ __ ] movies is what i
want to know i read a [ __ ] cast the
other day and i was like oh man
dude these [ __ ] people in a movie
it's like all the people they get it's
like i don't even recognize half the
names anymore it's like somebody's a tic
toc star and the other guy has an only
fans and then there's another dude
that's like
it's just like dude what is going on
with these movies they're just
cinderella dude it's just they're pumped
they just want your money and it's fine
dude but don't be tricked man
cinderella what does let's get loud have
to do with cinderella in the footage
cordon approaches the driver's side of
the car and sings through the window
before thrusting repeatedly at the
vehicle corn is one of the stars and
producers of cinderella which arrives on
amazon prime next month it stars cabello
and the classic fairy tale
i don't just
why is this even news who even cares
gordon's presence cordon's presence in
the film draws a mixed response upon the
release system dude everything if you're
not i'll tell you what if you're not
getting a mixed response
people are lying to you
i couldn't believe it i i
my my [ __ ] schaub uh saved somebody's
life and i was looking at somebody or
like save these kids from like
looking at his uh looking at their dead
mom in a crazy battered car crash and
people were just like bro okay he did
that but like nah and you're just like
bro what the [ __ ]
so what now what all right i'm you know
what i'll stick to my lonely i'll stick
to my business dude
it's like this [ __ ] uh what do you
call it
this uh jumping down everybody's throat
dude
[ __ ] on second thought let james
corden jump around in a [ __ ] rat
outfit who cares man
just don't scan your daughter's brain
donda [ __ ] i saw that thing a little
bit
and it's just like dude i don't you know
what it is dude i don't get art that's
it i'm out i don't get art never got art
but now i don't get art now i really
don't get art but when the guys started
making those big ass [ __ ] balloon
animals that was when i was like what
the [ __ ] now i don't get it completely
art basil or whatever the [ __ ] i don't
get it dude i don't get it
some guy tried to [ __ ] sell nothing
right
and now you got uh donda and the guys
are just running around driving around
in suvs slowly
and three guys are hanging near a house
and everyone's just sitting watching
this [ __ ] they're not even performing it
kanye has a mat they all got hoods on
and [ __ ] you don't even know if it's
kanye it could be the guy who pumps gas
down the street and he's just doing this
[ __ ]
and it's kanye just rapping [ __ ] like i
thought about killing myself i thought
about killing myself yeah i thought
about killing myself
and the baby was there i guess
they were all jogging and [ __ ] everyone
was dressed in the bulletproof what's up
with [ __ ] bulletproof vests dude with
the rappers with the bulletproof vests
just like you never know when you're
gonna get shot dude there's been like
three rappers that got shot
you know what's way more dangerous than
being a rapper being a regular person
they don't have security
just [ __ ] jogging around everyone was
jogging around and couldn't see their
face could barely breathe with their 40
pound bulletproof vest on dude i saw
some people on their hands on their
knees and [ __ ] just tired
you know kyle was like no matter what
don't stop running
some of them were just out of shape just
like no i got this and just like hands
on their
[ __ ] man i didn't know his album was so
long the last one was only like 44
minutes
donda
sorry guys had to go to the bathroom a
little bit um
dude how about
this thing that happened
this past week which which is absolutely
[ __ ] insane these headlines are just
some of them are click bait
but like this one is not when i read
this article it's on newsweek manthro
man throws his penis out of car while
fleeing police
says he cut it off to save the world
first of all imagine if that worked like
i just keep like
like imagine the police are [ __ ]
chasing after him and then all of a
sudden
they pull them over and much to this guy
chagrin that they were like you know
we're glad you ran out of gas because we
were trying to stop you to thank you
dude
we didn't know what the [ __ ] was going
on your penis flew out of the window but
we were going to arrest you until
we actually realize it helped us find
the leader of bin laden and cure world
hunger so
dude
imagine while he was driving
first of all dude
nascar
sign a mop
i can't
like texting and driving is hard enough
but cutting your deck off
slicing off your dick while doing sandy
that's two hands [ __ ] tax you could do
with one and drive that's two-hand [ __ ]
dude
he he's driving with one hand goes like
this [ __ ] the world gotta save the
[ __ ] world imagine the dude gotta
save the [ __ ] [ __ ] it dude starts
driving with his knees his dick gets
pushed up because his knees are together
grabs a what knife i guess he's driving
with a knife yanks it up slices it off
i like to imagine he has one of those
[ __ ] rolly windows [ __ ] tossing it
out and imagine the police
just
do you imagine the police say what the
[ __ ] is that imagine it [ __ ] wound up
dude
time's going to go on for s i'd say
something i like to imagine
time
eventually everything's gonna be done
right because just time's gonna just
keep going
like like like somebody out there has
said
for real oh my god the monkey ate all of
our underwear like that's happened
there's been too many people too many
monkeys and too many underwears that
somebody said that sentence some at some
point
right
and
the cutting off dick thing has already
happened tons of times you think this is
the first guy that ever cut his dick off
her throat out the window it's not i got
news for you it's not
i got news for you if you think that you
live with rose tinted glasses
because watch out for them dicks flying
out them cars because it happens it's
happened before many times this guy's
not the first he might have been the
first one to do it and save the world
turns out he wasn't because this
happened
on 8 28 and it's past that now and al
qaeda is still at large right
but
there will be the time
there will absolutely be the time where
a guy's being chased
just because time just keeps happening
a guy's being chased he'll cut off his
dick throw it out the window and it will
fly in somebody's mouth
it will happen
and all i'm saying is i can't wait for
that dude because technically
everything happens
as time keeps going unless the world you
know some big ass bomb or these big ass
aliens come to [ __ ]
right
oh no
imagine dude
flips over like one of those [ __ ] old
shows with eric roberts on the movie a
movie with eric roberts or any movie
that has [ __ ] car chases
some gene hackman [ __ ]
what's that french connection
where they take the [ __ ]
you know that one [ __ ] ass cop
bro if i'm a cop and you give me the
undercover car nah i don't want that
bitch-ass siren that goes up
like
i oh there he is dude
[ __ ] our cover
[Music]
you know what i mean dude i want this
straight across [ __ ] one i want the
straight across sirens that go blue and
red i don't want that bitch-ass little
just red portable one
you got to bring it to i want when you
get fired from the force they're like i
want to i'm going to need your badge
your gun and your your side piece and
your [ __ ] ass [ __ ] i need your [ __ ]
ass siren
hand over your [ __ ] ass siren
on the dash just go gunk
tennessee man had an unorthodox and no
doubt a
painful response to being pursued by
police on wednesday morning tyson
gilbert 39 of cookeville tennessee
reportedly cut off his penis and threw
it out the window of his honda accord of
course he had a honda accord no doubt
nobody's throwing a [ __ ] dick out of
bentley
while fleeing officers
or like an an accurate integra would be
the number one
you know with a [ __ ] spoiler on it
the chase began duh man in high school
there were so many acura integras when i
was a kid dude
all the asians had a man they just
[ __ ] ruled with those acura integris
the chase began when police found him
and they all had [ __ ] girls they all
had their girlfriend dangling from the
i stand by this and i always say this
[ __ ]
asians either have their significant
other a picture of their significant
other
dangling from the rearview mirror or a
picture
of them standing outside of their car in
their wallet i i [ __ ] stand by that
dude
i love making up [ __ ] that's not real
that is secretly real dude
i guarantee you a high percentage for
real is like that dude
the chase began when police found him
parked partially in the way of traffic
on highway 70 near the town of dowell
town
speaking to radio station
wlje tennessee highway patrol thp
trooper bobby johnson
said that the man took off when officers
initially tried to signal him with their
lights officers ultimately ended up
pursuing gilbert across two counties
from blah blah blah somewhere along the
way he managed to cut off his own penis
huh dude wow
it sucks man
it's just sad that like people like are
so mentally not well
you know
like it really is like let's get
actually real for a second like dude
oh
god
like being so
crazy that you're gonna go through that
much pain
to cut off your penis
to to think that you're doing it for the
greater good
like imagine the whole world
just watching that guy do it they'd all
be screaming no no no no no and he's
just like nah i gotta do it for y'all
it's like dude just
take telephone
just take 40
40 milligrams of citalopram
instead of cutting your deck off
nah man i don't know what they put in
that
[ __ ] oh everyone thinks that the
government is trying to [ __ ] chip
everyone i don't know a dude who uh
chipped me man chip me
hey government know where i am all the
time it's all good know where i am my
house
know where i am the coffee bean know
where i am
either my house or the coffee bean
hey government
i love that dude it's always the guy
screaming no no way dude i'm not letting
the government know where the [ __ ] i am
what do you do almost stay at home dad
they know where you are
they know where they are chip or not
your friends know where you are you
think the government doesn't
[ __ ]
the people are mad at the wrong [ __ ]
like people think that bill gates and
jeff bezos is trying to take over the
world bro how about the fact that
they're just probably anybody with that
much money is an absolute insane person
you [ __ ] so many people over
you don't get
700 got drillion dollars without being a
piece of [ __ ] to people
you don't you don't you have to be a
certain type of person
to be a jeff bezos to be a [ __ ]
whatever his name was bill gates
to be that guy even what's his name
everyone who liked the apple guy what's
his [ __ ] name
steve jobs
everyone [ __ ] loved him that dude you
don't get that much money
and you're not that successful unless
you are a complete [ __ ]
you cannot be as successful as the rock
without being a complete [ __ ] that's
on my mama that's on god dude every
president a complete [ __ ] dude i
don't care who it is
it's so annoying when people are like
well this person lies in that person
what about the fact that they're all
complete [ __ ] dude what kind of
[ __ ] do you have to be to think oh i
could run this country i don't care how
much school you went to i don't care how
much money you have i don't care how
good-looking you are how much of a great
family member you are i don't care what
you've done for the world if you think i
could rule america you are a complete
[ __ ] trump biden obama [ __ ] all
of them dude
they ran the country grover cleveland
[ __ ] uh george washington george
washington may be the only not [ __ ]
because he was the first one he's like
okay i'll do it maybe not maybe not but
probably [ __ ]
then immediately after him there's no
way john adams wasn't an [ __ ] because
he was just like oh i'll do what he did
[ __ ] dude
all those [ __ ]
poke even and i don't even really know
his first name dude [ __ ]
abe lincoln [ __ ] they're all
[ __ ] if you think you can run the
country you're an [ __ ]
you asked me to be the president i go
like this no no no way dude you sure
yes
and i
am an [ __ ]
imagine the kind of [ __ ] you have to
be to be the president
straight the [ __ ]
up
it's insane dude it's insane all the
other rulers we think that they're all
[ __ ]
america just because this is america we
think that they're dude and this is not
coming from a political thing i'm
talking about people who think they can
do this [ __ ] better than everyone else
you have to have a little of that
but all of it
you have to have other [ __ ] wrong with
you it's just it that's it that's it
dude that's it
everybody i admire
like to the truest form
that i know in my life
i know
they wouldn't want to be president
i'll leave that to someone you know who
has read more books than me or whatever
the [ __ ]
so don't come at me with the political
agenda i don't like any any of the
presidents dude i just want to live i
want to be left alone i want to be
chilling i want to be with my family you
know what i mean i want to be kissing my
wife and hug on my son that's what i
need that's what i want to be want to be
chilling out with my friends i want to
be laughing making fun of people and
that's it
what do you think how much you think you
got to have to where that's the thing
because there's got to be the cutoff
right there's got to be the cutoff of
like you know if you have a billion
dollars europe like warren but what's
his name warren buffett right that guy
just with the way he i go to mcdonald's
every morning and i'd always bring the
correct change and i get the same thing
every morning i just like i'm so you're
not normal dude
get the [ __ ] at least super size it
you know what i mean
i don't like these quirky [ __ ] rich
guys
like just
you know it's like
i bring every yeah he's cute yeah i get
it and this is a comedy podcast he's a
great dude okay
but it's like dude get a steak
have a chef
actor singer dancer chef new yorker
it's insane dude
sorry i don't even know like even rock
star and i i don't think comedian is
that way i know that i'll probably get
some [ __ ] for that but like
rock star like front man sing like and i
don't mean
uh
you know jack johns whatever the [ __ ]
guy who plays with no shoes on
this is so annoying
or john mayer i'm not talking about
these guys i'm talking about
like [ __ ] guys who go
like those guys in the 80s they were all
insane [ __ ] dude
and they showed you and you gave them
money for it that's what the president
is basically except you think it's like
nice because he's in a suit not going
i don't know dude what the [ __ ] frank
do i know
so that's it you guys are great um thank
you very much you know i i really enjoy
you guys listen to this podcast like and
subscribe and hug on that uh
bell notification you know honestly
subscribe and like it helps with the
algorithm and all that you know your boy
gets more views and if we're trying to
grow this cult we're trying to grow this
cult so uh we love you thanks for
listening um and you can go to
crystalia.com go get that merch you can
get the go medium and sometimes stay out
you get the life rips [ __ ] hoodie and uh
we got more merch coming too and then we
have uh other ones too i can't they're
our camera off but just [ __ ] good
[ __ ] we spend time trying to make this
merch good um so rep this cult hey guys
so that's the episode for youtube if
you'd like to see the rest of the
episode go on over to
patreon.comcrystalia and sign up to see
the rest of it and also you get other
things when you are a patreon member
like an extra episode a month and
there's plenty of uh months that we've
been on patreon so you get all access to
those backlog episodes and then also uh
there's another segment i do called
review mode um that comes out bi-weekly
and then behind the scenes stuff and all
sorts of [ __ ] but it's a community
there's a discord we do watch alongs and
it's fun man i'm having fun with it so
sign up if not uh we appreciate you uh
we appreciate you either way so thanks a
lot guys
[Music]
[Laughter]
congratulations
[Music]
thank you
here we go
knock him out the box wreck knock him on
rack